Eh bien, c'est un malin celui-là
comment tu vas l'appeler ?
Que des singes  vraiment tu crois ?  Ce sont des bêtes sauvages (lointain)
Il nous as sauvée la vie
Il a été remarquable
C'est toi ?
T'es César ?
depuis le temps qu'on te cherche
Dites à votre colonel : Nous ne sommes pas des bêtes sauvages
"coups de feu"
99 cible acquise (talkie-walkie)
Préparez vous à vous battre.
Il m'ont trop pris
Ma maison,
ma famille,
et tout les jours des singes sont tués
Houra ! Houra !
Humain est malade, singe devient malin
alors humain tue singe mais, mais pas moi
je cours.
Il faut savoir renoncer a notre humanité
afin de pouvoir sauver l'humanité
Toute l'histoire de l'humanité
n'as mener qu'à ces instants
Si nous le perdons
notre planète deviendras
la planète des singes.
"Musique épique"
Ensemble !
Singes !
Fort !
"Musique épique"